what's the see the devil trouble this is  Trafalgar Square they'll have one  McDonald chair pass they call this the  London Eye but it's a ferris wheel why  do they call it a tie  here's some errybody crap some more  Harry Potter crap and that's a big band  you know Big Ben used to be my nickname  with the ladies true story because I had  a very long Tower if you know what I  mean I also have clocks on the tip of  mine and this is the Tower of London  this is where they chopped off their  heads of traders traders like Sir Nancy  Pelosi the Duke of Hillary and Prince  failing New York Times and this is  Stonehenge which was clearly vandalized  by the Mexicans  you